>>
GERMAIN: How many people in here have had
an idea for business that they think could
work? Hands up. Okay. That's pretty good.
And how many people tried to make that idea
happen? A few hands, two hands. And how many
people made that idea work and it's a roaring
success now? Two people. That's great. I think
later we'll have great ideas of businesses.
I think most of them happen on Friday nights
about 9:00 P.M. in pubs with your mates and
you go, we got to do this thing one day, you
know, maybe. And people talk a good game,
but rarely get down, to actually start things,
you know, make the idea happen. And I guess
that's where Innocent got to--Rich, Adam,
and John are the three founders of Innocent.
I went to university with them. We managed
this since we were 18. And they were always
the people at the university who were going
to do something, you know, they're always
doing stuff, you know, basically, in terms
of being quite entrepreneurial in trying to,
you know, make a quick buck. And I definitely
wasn't really happy, just not being entrepreneurial.
And obviously, I have changed now in an incredibly
dynamic character. And it's interesting knowing
them back then, knowing them at about 18 or
so. And about the time we got to about 24,
when we left university and done a few other
things, they'd been talking about it for so
long that we should start a business. What
should we do? I don't know, but we should
just have a business. It would be great, wouldn't
it? Wait a minute, why should we have a business?
Yeah, I said the business, what should it
be? I don't know. They didn't, you know, they
didn't really know what they were going to
do, but you knew that they were going to do
something and they just have to get to an
idea, an idea that would work and act on it.
And Smoothie was, fortunately, for us, the
idea that works in the beginning and still
works today. Interestingly, the idea--some
of the ideas didn't work. This is one of the
ideas that didn't work. This is the--can anyone
tell me what that is? Easy, bath, but even
more--even more specifically? A death trap,
good, is the electric bath, the not-patented
electric bath. The patent is going if anyone
wants it. I think there's a company in Japan
called Auto Bath where they actually make
something in this realm. But the idea, the
idea behind it was great. And again, it was
really, like, 9:00 P.M. Friday night, pop
up idea, which is... I hate to run baths.
It's pretty boring. What do you do while you're
waiting? You know, just hanging around especially
with, you know, specifically British plumbing.
You know, if you ever lived in a flat where
the water comes out, you know, when it takes
20 minutes to run a bath, that is a real pain
in the bum. So, how can we make this? How
can we make people's bath experience a better
place? And the only idea was that you could
kind of automate it. So, getting up in the
morning, let's say 7:15 A.M. and knowing that
your bath has already run to the right depth,
has the correct temperature, has the right
amount of bubble bath in it, is an amazingly
rewarding experience if only I could have
that experience. Well, I can't because I don't
have the electric bath. But maybe one day
you can use your electric bath because we're
going to design it and make it and that are--how
many hotel rooms are in the U.K.? Thousands.
We're going to get the electric bath with
every one of those. And how many new built
homes were there being built at the end of
the night? There's thousands, maybe tens of
thousands. We're going to get the electric
bath into every new home built by [INDISTINCT],
Wimpey, Taylor Woodrow, all those guys are
going to buy the electric bath. This is a
business with massive potential or death and
after, you know, after getting quite--seriously
quite excited about it for awhile, always
realized that when they would ultimately have
to go and sell these ideas to people that
might invest and give them cash to who wins
their business, they were going to have to
get past this one issue, the death trap issue.
But, you see, I would have been a great investor,
straight to the point. And so it never actually
made it to business plan phase. Luckily, some
other ideas, the [INDISTINCT] and... It's
amazing actually because the electric bath
is our favorite comedy idea that didn't work.
We get sent quite lot of ideas now. People
are going, oh, you know, Innocent, you seem
like quite a friendly approach with people.
I have this idea for business and I think
you should make, you know, maybe you could
help me develop my idea for the cat bag, which
is--it's an amazing device, people have cats
and cats shed hair. I have a lovely flat and
I love my cat but there's hair everywhere.
What I'd love is this little, like, boiler
suit bag thing that I can put my cat in, and
so my flat will be clear and there will be
no hair in the flat. My cat could be happy
and I also support [INDISTINCT] boiler suit
bag thing, without, you know, but without
that person getting to the second step, which
is a like--what happens when the cat wants
to go poo. What happens then? I don't want
to be near the bag then. What happens when
the cat wants to do other stuff, run free?
How you going to take the bag off? But we
got--we seriously got send out as a business
idea that somebody believed in. The other
one--and there's a theme here. The other one
was dog nappies. We've been pitched dog nappies
because one of the scourges of life is the
fact that you spread dog poo in the park,
and wouldn't it be great if dogs just have
little, you know, little nappies they walked
around in and then you're going to have to,
like, scoop up with a plastic bag and they'll
[INAUDIBLE]. So you make a couple of ideas
here if you fancy and start your own business,
cat bag, nappies. I have thought really stupidly.
I pitched three or four ideas to you there
quite quickly, which is what we were trying
to do back--about 10 years ago. What we realized
by the end of it in terms of having a great
idea was that we subsequently come up with
this thing called the Granny Test. In Hollywood
it would be the Elevator Pitch where you are
an aspiring screenwriter and you've got, you
know, you bump into Steven Spielberg on the
left and say, right, Spielberg, I've got a
great idea for a movie, it features a cat
that wears a bag and this dog and a nappy,
is going to be amazing. And you have that,
you know, you have that 10 seconds to maybe
make your [INDISTINCT] or fall flat in your
face. Our thing is slightly more prosaic because
we know that you're not going to bump in Spielberg
that often. Also, this is called the Granny
Test because most people got a granny. If
you don't have a granny, you can borrow somebody
else's granny to [INDISTINCT] around. And
if you can't explain your business idea in
over a cup of tea with your granny, then it's
rubbish, then it sucks, because, you know,
your granny sees they're going to--you know,
if you get, "Oh, that's nice, dear. That's
okay. That's pretty. That might work," if
you just get a blank look and more tea, then
it's probably--it's probably not going to
work. Well, I think, in seriousness, testing
out in your friends and your family is the
only--is the only sure way it's beginning
to work out, that it's going to work. Like
that whole [INDISTINCT], because I don't--I
want to understand what's going on inside
[INDISTINCT] chap's brains apart from what's
probably not there. Maybe they--they broke
the mold. Or maybe the grannies were really
clever. So the second law of--or the second
bit we get to is, so having a great idea is
crucial for every business. I've come to skip
through it in five minutes with a few funnies,
but actually, you know, it's rare that great
ideas come. What we've also learned is that
when you think, "I've got a ton of ideas to
start a business," you start thinking like
an inventor. You start thinking that you've
got to invent something that nobody has ever
seen before. And, actually, what you tend
to do is not be an inventor. You tend to just
be an improver or an adapter, just tend to
make things a bit better. So Smoothie has
all ready existed, right? We just make them
better, which got better ingredients. We created,
you know, a business and a brand that we think
sold the idea of Smoothies better to people.
We didn't invent. We're not crazy guys with
beards hiding in sheds. I have a shed. But
then, when you've had your idea, you got to
start and that's--arguably, that's even more
difficult than having the idea, because where
do we start. So where do we buy 10 tons of
mangoes? Who's got--do we need a machine,
or do we just do it ourselves? Do we just
hire loads of people to chalk it up? What
about bottles? Where do you get the bottles
from? We have to make those? And then somebody
is going to get them all in the shops. We
didn't know any of this stuff. We really didn't
know any of this stuff. And so, the starting
part is the hardest part because you just
have to start somewhere. You just have to--how
many people in this room have done, say, a
dissertation or a Ph.D., thesis, or something
in their time in education? How many of you?
And how many of you started without delaying,
without procrastination, without futzing around,
without drinking coffee, without just not
doing it for quite a lot of time? How many
of you just started like that? Come on, geeks.
Come on. Somebody did. No, you don't. You
don't. Even if you kind of know--even if you
kind of know what you're going to do, the
human race is based on a healthy dose of procrastination,
and it's the same in starting a business.
You don't really know where and when to start.
I guess in the end, we finally figured out.
It wasn't about the fact that we didn't know
how to make Smoothies. It was more of the
point that we didn't really know if anyone
would like them, would like the stuff we were
going to make. And so the place where we started
was in August '98 and that was in Parsons
Green, you know, Parsons Green and it's about
[INDISTINCT]. It's a small triangle of land
and this used to be small [INDISTINCT], on
the green, and we took a stall there, a small
stall. I've got a sign up above the stall
saying, "Do you think we should give up our
day jobs?" And we had a bin, one that said
yes, and a bin that said no, and lots of smoothies,
lots of homemade proto smoothies on this table
and asked people about [INDISTINCT] come to
try them that weekend, to just tell us if
they like them. And that was how--that was
how we started and that's--that's one of those
stories about Innocent that we've told lots
of times to lots of people. And the more you
tell it, the more it starts turning into this
weird myth. And you know, Bryan Blessed was
there, I think, and he tried to... And Paul
[INDISTINCT], he was there. There were all
these amazing people there, actually, [INDISTINCT].
It's not why I've told you those two there,
but anyway. I guess what I'm trying to say
is that we really did it. We really did test
our drink that way with those people, by putting
the sign up and we made it--but we made it
that little tipping point, because between
the three of them, Rich and Adam, they'd agreed
on that weekend, if enough people say yes,
if enough people throw their empties in to
the yes bin, so we should give up our day
jobs. On Monday, we gave up our jobs. And
unluckily--luckily for us now, but unlucky
for them at that time, because it kind of
freaked out, the yes bin was full at the end
of the weekend and the no bin was empty, apart
from three bottles from their [INDISTINCT].
They--on the Monday, they resigned from their
seemingly decent well-paying jobs and started.
In fact, that's a story we've always told.
They only told me while I was writing the
book about somebody called the chairman with
a consultant on the Sunday evening, because
now, we were really scared that we actually
have to do it, that the people had spoken,
the people of Parsons Green. They actually
had to go in and write their resignation letters.
The chairman at this point [INDISTINCT] piece,
and they said, "If it flips, if we flip it
and it's three times the same way, then we
definitely have to give up our jobs." And
it was three tails and they've kept the chairman.
He's at work. This is ultimately like the
big template used to get in the olden days.
And so, you know, thanks to the chairman,
we started the business on Monday--and the
people of Parsons Green, of course. And has
anyone ever seen our drinks with the one with
all the little hats? So we do that. We do
that once a year, in the winter, and that
raises money for Age Concern, gets money back
to a lot of elderly people who need to help
with paying their heating bills. And this
is a great idea--sorry, you'd have to read
the print. I just put it up there because
I have to grab it quickly. This guy down at
the bottom, Adam, he is called new Adam because
we already have an Adam, so he is new Adam.
And he came to work with us after a couple
of years and he has this thing where he knits.
He is a bit of a softie and a very lovely
man. And I think he knitted the first ever
little hat. See, for all that, it looked nice.
A hat in it, well, yeah, it does, right? Could
you do some work now? And he suggested this
idea, wouldn't it be great if, what, you know,
for a certain period, all the bottles in all
the shops have the little hats. Wouldn't that
be great? Well, yeah, but how about, you know,
how are we going to do that? Who is going
to do the hats? You know, all those questions,
all those panicky questions when a big idea
is sort of volunteered. How are we going to
do it? Who is going to do it? Who's going
to put the hats on? What does it mean? Is
it, you know, are the supermarkets going to
kick us out? Is there a health and safety
thing? You know, everyone worrying, and actually,
Adam is--where we sit, we kind of chanced
it. We said, well, if you think you can make
it work, make it work. Do it. And so he did.
And in the first year--I think it says up
there--a few thousand, a few thousand on the
shelves, not much impact. The next year, a
few more, you have few more. But he did it
last year, you know, half a million hats on
the shelves, all the stalls in [INDISTINCT],
I think, we did it with last year. Every [INDISTINCT]
store and raised, you know, 4 million quid
for Age Concern, and it's just a little micro
example of how if you have a really, you know,
seemingly quite dumb idea, but mighty quite
amusing. You know, but you sit down and you
make it work and you actually just start doing
it. It's the starting that seems to be the
thing. Anyway, that's what we think. Now,
one of my favorite ladies, [INDISTINCT] on
TV [INDISTINCT]. Is anyone familiar with her?
With Pam AKA [INDISTINCT]? Yeah? Who doesn't
know who she is? Okay. That doesn't matter,
because you can see from here that she is
a striking lady and a very important lady.
And we have another test. So we have the granny
test. But our starting idea is called--is
the East Enders test, patterned after East
Enders, the TV soap. And it goes a bit like
this that, usually, when you have an idea
for business, you have another job, right?
You may be working at Google or at Innocent,
you may have this idea that you have all your
friends that you really need to start, but
you get home and, you know, East Enders is
on and there's some wine, and I'm just going
to sit down and drink some wine and watch
East Enders and maybe work on the business
thing tomorrow, you know, or maybe in the
weekend. I'll do it in the weekend, you know,
when there is no danger of East Enders being
on TV, but they might be dangerous for some
wine. And people, again, people just procrastinate,
people don't get to it. The test is, test
is, don't watch East Enders tonight, don't
drink the wine, don't watch When Pets Turn
Bad, don't watch--don't watch anything. Turn
off, get rid of all booze and sit down and
write your business plan, or talk to your
friends and plan how you're going to start
your business. There is no other way and there
is no better time than tonight when you get
home. I'm not advocating everyone in the room.
You could get in trouble from the people in-charge.
But the East Enders test, again, is just another
test of whether, I guess, whether you are
entrepreneurially minded and whether you get--whether
you really care about your idea as well. So
that's the East Enders test. Go, go away.
Great. Okay. So does anyone know what car
this is? Punto? It's not the Punto. It's the
Uno, the Uno, the Fiat Uno. It's a great car.
And persistence, so far what we've done, we
have an idea and we've made ourselves start,
you know, stop whatever it is, start the business.
And so at this point when you go to see people
and say we got this great idea and we just
started, we started to make some smoothies
and people really liked them--and, hi, Mr.
Big Juice Maker, can you make our drinks?
No. No. Why can't you make it? Well, the haven't
got any preservatives in, I haven't got the
additives to make them cheaper, they don't
use concentrates and sure, they're going to
go off really quickly and no one is going
to buy them because they're too expensive.
So that's basically what we heard for--well,
every time we went and talked to anyone who
would be able to help us make our drinks.
And so I'm just--I already get really upset.
This then is missing out. We have to be super,
super persistent, really persistent, because
everyone tells you, no, because you're nobody,
right? You're just three blokes with a Fiat
Uno. And one meeting in particular sticks
out. It was in Wales. It was down [INDISTINCT],
quite a long drive with some people who made
drinks and they make big, they made such a
scale that we couldn't believe it. We thought
they might have a little machine in the corner
that we could start using, you know, and make
our drinks, if you don't mind. And we had
to ask. We had to ask everyone. That's what
this thing is about, just being persistent.
We asked everyone. Well, this was a special
day because Adams, Fiat Uno, which was the
company car at that time, which he'd got on
his 17th birthday, so it must have been about
almost approaching 10 years old. And he got
into his car. He remodeled it because it didn't
have electric windows. He'd installed his
own electric window on the driver's side.
I actually thought that was really cool when
he was 17. It was really uncool when you're
27 because the electric window didn't work
and it was always stuck. It got stuck down.
And so driving to Wales in the rain with the
window stuck down in really sort of cheap
suits, but trying to look like businessmen,
but, you know, obviously not really [INDISTINCT].
And getting all the way down and being late
and being very wet in the car, fashioning
impromptu windows out of newspapers and magazines
in bags and stuff, and getting there and getting
out of the car and the car park, it was right
where the meeting room window was--they looked
out, basically, on these idiots who arrived.
And we got out and we're bedraggled, getting
there with little bits of paper for their
PowerPoint ready and went, "Oh, what do we
do," and went in, and we're offered towels.
Our reception, the only business to leave
a wet patch in reception, we [INDISTINCT],
and then getting to the meeting room and establishing
pretty much after about seven minutes, there's
absolutely nothing they could do for us. We
offered them nothing of interest either. We'd
driven all that way and got very wet for nothing.
But they were very kind because they offered
us petty money for the way back, and that's
very true. The interesting thing is, the interesting
thing is now [INDISTINCT] you there or not.
I'm not going to because this doesn't really
matter. But we worked with this business now.
We put millions of pounds of business their
way, you know, every day, every week. No,
for every year, that means [INDISTINCT] every
day, I'd get fired. That's not my part of
business. And we spend a lot of money with
them and I don't know if there are still people
from that day 10 years ago. We don't talk
about that day with them anyway. But it's
just a strange thing, this little loop back
then, you know, about being persistent we've
become one of their biggest customers, which
is a bit crazy. I need to tell you their office
is pretty uninteresting. But on the Fiat Uno,
the Fiat Uno, the only thing I can say about
Fiat Uno is, I was delivering a fridge to
[INDISTINCT] for our second year, still our
company car, slash delivery van slash everything
else, and it caught fire in [INDISTINCT] and
High street and the engine blew up and I just
leapt away like Steven Seagal from the blaze,
but Adam was really cursing me because it
was his favorite car. Okay. That's just a
little picture of the inside of the entrepreneur's
brain, because that's what happens, is that
everyone tells you no. I always remember going
to a factory where they do the--put a print
on the cap, because they don't have any bottle
with it. Yeah, great. On the top, on the cap,
it says, instead of best before, it says,
"Enjoy by." And we used to have quite a big
discussion with the guy who operated the machine,
that prints on the cap, because we wanted
it to say, "enjoy by," because we think use
by, it's a really weird thing, how do I use
a smoothie? I mean, I don't use it. I, you
know, I enjoy it. I drink it. I enjoy it.
I imbibe, whatever so, you know, whatever
word you've got in there, we figured that
the people of Great Britain and further afield
were smart enough to understand by "enjoy"
that I meant, you know, best to drink it before
that day. But then, going to factory and trying
to explain that to the guy, you know, you'd
say, "Can we put 'enjoy by' on top?" And didn't
say, like... See, it worked, you know. Well,
we've actually put "best before" on the label
there, and we say, "For best before date,
see cap," because then they want to know what
that means anyway. Yeah, but there is way
we can do it, because what we do, we go to
the machine and we go "E-N-J-O-Y." You need
to go so we can do that. We can break through.
And after a few discussions, after [INDISTINCT]
getting really bored with us, we did it. We
changed it and, you know, "on your head be
it" type thing, we did get told off about
it a few times by the trading standards officer
that looked at our products, but we sent a
few letters and it eventually worked, established
that we were fine to do it. And so to this
day, we still say "enjoy by" on the caps and
that was just because we didn't, you know,
we were persistent and we didn't just listen
to all the nos, because people will always
tell you, no. I don't know. I mean, even now
at Innocent, I guess, in Google, you know,
you'll have an idea for something and you
find quite a few people to tell you what works,
what can't work, well, you know, that won't
work. It's all our duties to kind of politely
ignore yes and move on. And Richard tells
an interesting story and I don't, you know,
when he first told me this I was like, "Yeah,
that's not true." It's really not true, because
that's sort of the story that you hear in
class, but he swears it's true. His dad is
from Liverpool and went to school with a bloke
named Paul McCartney. He was in the same class
at school, and always remembers the day when
you have--at the end of [INDISTINCT], you're
allowed to do what you want, bring in--for
you, you bring something in. Paul McCartney
brought in his guitar who was about 10 or
12 years old, and the teacher, basically,
says to him, said, [INDISTINCT]. I'm lucky.
[INDISTINCT] know Paul McCartney? So I think
that was an awful response. It's harsh. [INDISTINCT]?
Yeah. Okay. Anyway, good. So, this is about
people, because then, it's what we do. We
have an idea, we started, we just started,
then we're really persistent, so we kind of
got the products up and running, and then
there's a bit where you have to find some
people to help you because, you know, three
people wasn't enough and then four people
wasn't enough, and then six, and then ten,
then twenty. I guess there's no better example
in the world than Google finding great people
and finding lots of great people quite quickly.
Hey, you're all great, by the way. So, I saw
this guy speak once. He was head of talent
at Apple, he has got around the world finding
great people to work at Apple and he was talking
to a lady. He told the lady about this, actually.
He told the lady about snipers. You know,
she was in a business of a certain size and
she was saying, well, you know, we've got
to this size now where there's a few hundred
of us in the business and there's loads of
great people. There's a few people that are
always having to go, you know, aren't particularly
positive, complaining about stuff, moaning,
you know, just--and he said, well, you mean
snipers? She said, yeah, they're snipers because
they're people kind of you can't see, who
are just chipping away at the fabric of the
business. And that's when he came out with
this and he said, well, you know, look--he
wasn't referring to bullet holes. Let's be
absolutely clear about that. He was just referring
to if you, you know, if there are people who
aren't working in your business, this is quite
sort of tough thing to hear, especially for
somebody, for us as a business, Innocent,
which was quite small and friendly and, you
know, slightly meek at the beginning, and
to hear--well, if people aren't working, then
they go, you know. This, businesses with the
wrong people in them ain't going to work.
And the story follows for when you hire people,
making sure you get the right person. There's
kind of a--there's a culture sometimes and
we've done it at Innocent a few times, because
we've been so desperate to get the right number
of people into building to do the right things.
You panic and you get people too quickly and
you haven't really taken the time to check
whether they're going to fit…I guess, culturally
is the word. You know, you got to make sure--there
is a culture of Google, there is a culture
of Innocent, and the people that come in and
work at our place have to be spot on in that
regard. And if they're not, then we just leave
the gap and we wait, and we wait, and we wait.
And, you know, it takes two years to finally
find the right person. Our head of products,
Lucy, who basically is responsible for inventing
new smoothies and inventing new recipes and
new products, we waited ages for her. We used
to send her letters, a leaflet stuck outside
her house, and we were on the line, I think,
but she didn't mind, I think. She still works
for us. But we really persisted in--we knew
that if we had her in the building, we'd have
somebody who can invent the right products
for us, and we didn't have that, and we decided
it was her, so we just kept going back to
her and back to her. We had this--we had a
bit of a gap. You know, we were just waiting
to get her, but we need, you know, she's here
today inventing good stuff. So no snipers,
no assholes, sounds really tough, but I'm
the last one. Just get great people for building.
Anyone know these people? Sometimes one person
knows Longaberger. Can anyone guess what Longaberger
do?
>> Baskets.
>> GERMAIN: Yes, very good. I know some people
would say, they, like, make picnics, or they
do, you know, just something like that, but
you knew. That's good. Longaberger make baskets,
and I think they're based in Columbus, Ohio,
and I think in the U.S. is pretty much the
biggest manufacturer of the shopping basket
that you get in the supermarket through to
this executive wicker, picnic hamper and they
do all sorts of baskets. And I like Longaberger
a lot and I have for a long time because they
built a giant basket. They built a massive
basket somewhere in Ohio and if you go to
longaberger.com, usually I say afterwards,
but this is definitely the first talk I've
had when more people have got laptops than
have no laptops, but it's--that's the culture.
You can just see loads of shots of the Longaberger
building, lit at night, in different angles,
across the lake. I mean, it's definitely a
thing of beauty. The thing I love the most,
the thing I love the most about Longaberger,
the Longaberger building isn't the--isn't
just the fact that the basket exists, it's
the fact that there was a meeting and there
was a meeting in the big room. Is there a
special room here where the big stuff gets
decided? No? You do have? No oak paneling?
Okay. Awful lot of respect for you. There's
a room, probably, but it wasn't in there because
they haven't build it at that time, but somewhere
where the board of Longaberger, I guess, the
chief executive, the MD, the CEO, whoever
it is, of the company have to sit down and
make a decision. And ultimately, one person
has to make a decision like this, it's the
budget for the new HQ, and it is millions
of dollars, millions. It's the most they've
ever spent on anything. And that person has
to decide whether to build the giant basket
or not, or whether to build a pretty regular,
you know, regular new HQ bit, like the last
one with better lifts, you know, or build
that. And somebody decided to build that one.
One person has to decide. This isn't--that
didn't happen by accident and so that's why
I love them. That's why I love them because
I get the feeling. If I were to work there
and if I met that person and if I met everyone
who worked there, there would be a real shared
sense of purpose about what we were doing,
you know. You don't forget what you're doing
if you work in there. You know where you're
going. You know where you're--you know even
when you're five miles away in a cloudy Monday
morning, you know what you do, because it's
there. So I love Longaberger, because they--because
ultimately the main thing, you know, everything
is marketing, right? There is old marketing
where, posters and stuff in TV and now, of
course, it's digital, you know, that kind
of old, it must be a picture and some words,
but that isn't marketing. You know, marketing
is everything, and that's--they don't have
to--I don't think they do ads. I don't think
they need to do ads? They just need to show
people, invite people over. They're fine.
These people have some work to do. When we
started Innocent, our--that was our name,
where we [INDISTINCT] Innocent. We had a handful
of innocents at that time. The first label
we designed was the now-really-famous-fast-tractor
smoothie brand. I don't know if you can see
that on the really fast tractor, which is
really suited up is the guy sitting there
who is, you know, looking really happy, and
big old sideburns, he's probably a farmer
and the idea was--what we were all about was
getting fruit from the country to town really
quickly so it would be super fresh. We had
a really fast tractor to help us do that and
we thought it was a great brand name. And,
you know, it might have been. I don't know.
We might be sitting here talking about a different
business today. That might be the great name.
We had some other names on the list. We found--this
was the best thing we found during the trawling
for stuff to put in the book. It's the list
of names and there was Monkey Vomit. There
was Hungry Aphid. There was one called, and
there were little comments in the spreadsheet
like, "Why is this a good name and why this
isn't a good name?" It's really--what was
one of them? Hey, that's just a bit too aroma
therapy, at least comments that worked. I
don't know what they--I don't know what we're
thinking at that time, but I'm really glad
that we call it Innocent. I'm really glad
it wasn't monkey vomit or fast tractor. But,
you know, where we started from--where we
started from just this little bottle on the
shelf, packaging is becoming incredibly important
to us. It was and still is our prime bit of
appetizing media, whatever space, you know,
to talk to people. Yeah, we do other conventional
bits of marketing, but I still believe that,
you know, the pack is the place where we interact
with people, a place where we talk to people,
and really have it called Innocent and not
fast tractor, or else our tone, our style
would have to go down a whole different flight,
you know, we would have to do farmer jokes
for 10 years. Red sky at night, you know,
where the smoothies really shine. Hilarious,
hilarious jokes like that. So we've made the
pack our place, you know, what we do on the
back of the pack is free rein, you know. I
remember how many conversation right at the
beginning which was--is a bit on a lot of
packaging which says, "Your statutory rights
are not affected." Okay, I don't know what
my statutory rights are. Oh, dear. And I don't
think I've been affected. Do you think anyone
else knows what they are? No. Let's not put
it on there. You know, all these things that
you've seen on packaging and stuff throughout
your life, you just think, "Oh, well, we don't--do
we need that?" Well, if anyone tells us we
need it, then we might put it back on later.
We just took loads of stuff off, which left
us loads of room for just having bit of fun,
which is bringing pictures of stuff that we'd
like, talking about things that we're interested
in, not necessarily fruit-related, not necessarily
health-related, just stuff, because people
like stuff, you know. People get bored if
you're just telling them the same things all
the time. People are more interested in...
We've got a picture of a little, the second
one from the left, that was really a small
dog with a jumper on, then people are going
to like that. I like dogs that wear jumpers.
The most important thing, obviously, apart
from the [INDISTINCT] when it comes down to
it is the stuff in the bottle, because in
the beginning we wrote this big marketing
plan. It was, you know, we're going to do
this and that, and one day we'll have a TV
advert and we'll, you know, we're going to
do this crazy thing [INDISTINCT]. Actually,
the only thing that people will really come
back to is good products. It doesn't matter
how fancy our bottles are, it doesn't matter
how good our website is, it doesn't matter
that we, you know, that we have a Twitter,
a goddamned Twitter feed. It doesn't matter
about any of those things really because when
people put the bottle into their mouth and
drink it, if it tastes rubbish, they will
not buy again. So you can do what you can
to kind of attract people to go to the fridge
in the first place, without anything that
you can then do and 95 percent of the work
that we have to do is make the product great.
After that, it's fine. After that, it's just
all gravy. And so, finding the best fruit,
getting in the kitchen, chopping into small
pieces, putting it into a blender, that's
how we invent the recipes, we don't have any
secret methodology. We buy fruit, we put it
in the blender, we mix it up, the stuff that
tastes good, we work it out to make it to
scale and then we put it in the shops. It's
pretty damn straightforward. And so making
great products is the only thing we care about.
So the pretty good things that worth the hardest
in the last few years is actually going backwards,
finding out where does great fruit come from,
because they're going to be truly huge. Want
to be big, want to be successful, want to
be profitable, want to be popular, and we're
going to be all those things, if we're going
to do all that, then we need to taste better
than everyone else and we need to know who's
got the best fruit. So, our--the team has
grown proportionately the biggest in Innocent
for the last few years is the procurement
team. They are the lucky people that get to
go to Costa Rica, or Uganda, or India to find
great fruit. They're the people with all the--like
all the cool travel gear, they got the best
bags that fold out into camp beds and falls
out into everything else. You know, they just--they're
always on the road and I'm really jealous
because I don't get to go on those trips.
But finding the best fruit is the thing. I
think I've got a few more minutes. Has anyone
got any questions to the end just so I know
so I can save my time? Yeah, cool. Okay. Somebody
asked. Where is that--where is that young
man who asked me about a banana phone? This
is the banana phone. It's on a special velvet
cushion on a plinth. We have a lot of time
to [INDISTINCT] our phone. We bought it in
Woolworths on Portobello Road right when we
began, which is our office was just on the
other road. We needed a phone in the office.
We thought it would be hilarious to have one
of fruit. And there it is. It's real. It still
exists. At the time when we first bought it,
it was the Batphone, you know, it was the
one phone in the office and when it went off
it was like, "Ah, who is calling?" "I don't
know. You have to pick up the phone to find
out." You know, it was the thing that could--it
could be the guy from [INDISTINCT], that we're
not--you know, what we're going to do? We
want that whole aisle to be your stuff. Whatever
you want, just have it. Or it could be--more
likely, which is your mom asking if you're
coming home in the weekend, will you bring
the [INDISTINCT]. Or, you know, just--but
you never knew who it was. It's very exciting.
Picking that phone up was a special moment.
And you'd go, hello, Innocent banana phone
and wait for the magic. And we didn't plan
this, but now at Innocent, when people pick
up the phone, if it's that number which has
been dialed, there's this crack team of people
that are devoted to answering the Innocent
banana phone, they call the people's champions,
they are just there to talk to people about
stuff. It might be a complaint, it might be
about the smoothie. It might be praise. It
might be, you know, just somebody who wants
to ask a question, something who wants to
tell us where they've been on holiday. It
could be anything at all. But they all come
to our banana phone. And if it doesn't get
answered in three rings, then every phone
in the office rings, every desk, every desk
rings, which is great, right, because it means
those guys might already be in a call and
it means that everyone in the office gets
to talk to whoever, who could it be, I don't
know, you have to pick up the phone to find
out. It could be anyone. And usually, basically,
it's the people that make our business work.
So if somebody who has spent one pound seventy-nine--not
you, [INDISTINCT]--somebody has spent, somebody
has spent one pound and seventy-nine on buying
a drink and wants to tell us about it and,
man, we need to--we really need to listen
to that person, and listen to the next time
he phones and the next time, and the next
time, because without them, we have no wages,
we have no business. They have the phone us.
We have to be phoned by them. The moment that
we get, you know, we kind of outsource that
bit and we don't know where those calls are
going and exactly what's happening with those
calls is the moment when I definitely start
worrying, when the reason we started Innocent
in the first place starts to kind of… So,
although it's just a plastic phone, it sums
up, you know, a greater relief and a high
purpose, or something like that. That's our
front door and we have... Again, we did that
because we thought it would be funny for just
one day and then the sign stayed there because
we still think it's funny. When people come
to the front door, they still kind of think
it's funny. We've only been burglared twice.
And both times, they just walked in and pretended
they were [INDISTINCT]. A lesson to us all
there. That is just a little wall when you
come in to reception. That's just stuff that
people have sent us. People are always sending,
making stuff out of instant cards and sending
us--there is this lady who makes us tapestries.
It just--well, sits there, makes the tapestries,
every once in a while it's nice to receive
a tapestry in the post. People have decided
that they really like what we do and they
really want to be involved and that's, you
know, I like that. It's nice receiving a lot
of stuff. Again, it's the physical version
of what people want to say and want to talk
about on the banana phones. It's just, you
know, people sending letter and sending ideas,
lots of ideas and new smoothie recipes, and
long, it may continue, you know, one day I'd
like a whole office just to be plastered in
that stuff we're working on. And that spirit
sort of openness and risking burglary extends
to our AGM, which actually happens this Saturday.
So we have this thing called a grownup meeting
every year where we just invite hundreds randomly
selected from a ballot Innocent drinkers and
they come and spend the Saturday with us and
just tell us stuff, tell us what they think,
tells us what's rubbish, because, you know,
we do those research groups and some stuff,
you know, adverts and things like that. And
they always spook me a bit. You know, this
research group thing I'm talking about, we
have eight people in the room, they ask probing
questions and everyone kind of says what they
think they should say to make themselves look
smart rather than just go [INDISTINCT]. Actually,
this is a wonderful, beautiful way of just
finding out what all these--what all these
people who spend their money on our drinks,
things about our business and we have a [INDISTINCT]
last year doing this. You know, the founders
tell people what we will be up to for the
next year, the next five years. Everyone gets
to meet, everyone gets to have some tea, cake,
ask some questions, find out some new stuff.
It seems like a really sensible thing to do,
and so you make sure that, you know, you've
checked the building's insurance, stowed all
laptops away, our building's manager just
get [INDISTINCT]. That's kind of our end.
That's the thread that runs through the book.
It's telling a story of what we've done and
how we've done it. And the fact is it has
been--[INDISTINCT] it has been uncomplicated,
right? It's a pretty uncomplicated product.
We're relatively uncomplicated people. We
got a pretty simple idea at the beginning.
We've just tried quite hard. We've been very
persistent in everything we've done. We haven't
really taken no for an answer. And if you
come to our place, you're all welcome to come
if one of you fancy. It still feels exactly
the same as it did 10 years ago. There's more
people there. There's more stuff. But I don't
know. It's quite difficult for me to describe
having been there 10 years, the... It doesn't
feel any different showing up to work today
as it did back then. I just got--just got
more friends. I'm just very fortunate that
you'd get higher friends. And this is the
last thing I just wanted to show you, because
[INDISTINCT]. It just shows the importance
of always listening to the people that...
The importance of making sure you're always
listening to the customer. That's my lot.
Thank you very much for listening. Thanks.
>> Okay. Any questions?
>> So, Coke bought 10 to 20 percent last month,
can you talk a little bit of how you expect
that to change to come to your company?
>> GERMAIN: Pretty much, well, the reason
we chose Coke because we talked to about 18
to 25 different--well, individuals, corporations,
investment groups, they were the only people
who didn't want us to do anything different.
Everyone else wanted us to--have you thought
about doing this, if you thought about changing
this, if you thought about moving your office
here, if you thought about having more people,
less people, you know, we'd like to be involved
in that thing that part. And there people
who said, "You seem to know what you're doing,
you seem to be quite good at it. Carry on."
And that's--that was basically--that is the
rationale. We want--when we need more money,
so when we drive in Europe we got nine offices
in Europe and now it's sold in 40 countries,
but we are, you know, we are starting to spread
ourselves quite thin. And if we really want
to in the next couple of years, I think, grow
probably in Europe as we have done in U.K.
we just needed some capital to do that. And
Coke's people just said, great. It's an investment,
right? If we get bigger, their investment
grows. They're not stupid and neither we.
>> Talk a little bit, a bit more about your
footprint. You just mentioned that you are
in 14 countries?
>> GERMAIN: Yes.
>> And what are the biggest competitors, how
are you doing in those countries?
>> GERMAIN: We're in all, all the bits of
Europe that we can kind of get to easily,
because, well, we have a manufacturing hub
in Rotterdam and we have--also make lots of
stuff in U.K. So, it's basically what we can
get to from those places. So about as far
as we go is Finland, Austria, South of France,
and everything. I guess what we call Western
Europe and Scandinavia. I guess the competition
there is Tropicana, is that Pepsi Coke? And
Chiquita on mainland Europe, the big banana
company who now make [INDISTINCT]. And then,
in each country you go, go to Germany, you
go to France, you go to Holland, they'll be
some guys like us starting up trying to do
something new. See, we kind of--we kind of
find ourselves slightly in the middle of the--the
new little guys and the big people like Pepsi
coke, kind of whoever are doing it. So we
could get in that mark, but that's why we
got to do it quickly, because if you don't,
there's no place for us and we won't--there
will be relevance for us. So, we need to do
things now.
>> Who you--do you have any kind of big critics
like the amount of--you all have to spend
to ship all this stuff half way across the
world.
>> GERMAIN: Yeah, oh yeah.
>> Who is your biggest producer?
>> GERMAIN: I guess--I don't know if there's
like a specific group of critiques. There
are people who drink in some drinks, who definitely
keep us on our toes. Now, we appeal to an
audience with, you know, those people who
care about those issues, so if we--if they
think that we're in the verge of screwing
up, they'll let us know. That's what, that's
what a good insurance policy to have to know
that they care enough to tell you. I mean,
we don't air freight anything. Everything
goes by land, rail, sea, so I mean you come
out on massive wedge for the missions if you
don't have it right. You know, some other
businesses, all the people who move food around
the world do air freight and that seems kind
of crazy to us and we tried to stay as local
as possible. Mangoes, they not grow that well
in the U.K., so we, you know, some stuff we
have to go and get somewhere else, but we
will always be as, you know, sustainable as
we can possibly be. 2007, we launched the
world's first the 100% recycled plastic bottle
to be used in a drink. Interestingly we were
actually talking to Coke during the investment
process a lot. That's quite interesting to
do that, you know. I wonder if we can do that.
Just tell us more about it. Now, if we can
do things that make larger companies change
the way that they do business, then I'm all
for continuing the way that we do business
and you know, working from within some of
that is a really interesting thing [INDISTINCT]
in the future. [INDISTINCT] against no specific
group of people, just good people who drink
our drinks.
>> So, as the business grows bigger or more
on the spotlight and the--so I've heard of
the exploding Smoothies.
>> GERMAIN: Yes.
>> Question is, what are your biggest fears?
And is it more about customer perception?
>> GERMAIN: Probably not the health and safety
stuff because they're the things that we can
to get to quite quickly and the exploding
Smoothies stuff you referred is just if a
Smoothie gets too warm, its fruit, it ferments.
We used to have these old caps that weren't
so good as staying on the bottles. Now, we
have some new caps that have some kind of
venting. So we sorted that one out. That's
fine. I guess my biggest fear is just about
getting big and--Well, my greatest fear in
life is just getting big and old and slow,
fat, you know. I don't want to be like that.
I want to retain, you know, an inquiring mind.
I want our business to stay on its toes. That's
always question to things that happens. Because
when you get bigger, that's when it starts.
Someone says no to you guys. Okay. I don't
want to. I'd like to still be the annoying
person in the room. The same, I. Why, I got
a three-year-old daughter, but she does it.
Why, why? Why, why? I just keep, you know,
she never--she wants answers. You know, I'd
like our business to stay [INDISTINCT].
>> What would you be doing if it wasn't for
Innocent?
>> GERMAIN: Personally speaking, what would
I be doing? What would I be doing now if I
haven't--if Innocent didn't happen 10 years
ago, I'd probably--I was a teacher before,
I was an English teacher. So, I'd probably
be teaching. [INDISTINCT]
>> Yeah. If you think yourself way back again
when you just started everything, how did
you go about, I'm sure thinking that would
the hardest part of, you know, after you have
the idea and you have your vision, how did
you go about getting funding? And how did
you keep persistence in asking probably big
banks, small banks to get the funding for
you?
>> GERMAIN: So, the persistence became very
useful. At the beginning every bank that I
spoke to said no to us. Every VC, venture
capital said no to us. Every individual who
had money said no to us. Everyone said no
to us. So you're like three blokes who never
made a Smoothie before in your lives. You
have you no experience of food and drink,
none of you. And it was only the very, very
last guy after we'd sent an email to everyone
in our address books saying, "Do you know
anyone rich?" in the subject line, and one
person who'd worked with John, a new guy from
[INDISTINCT], American who said sometimes
invested in stuff. Crazy. I went to see Morris
and he invested the first--he has 20% of the
business, roughly 20% of the business. Biggest
money to [INDISTINCT]. We still see Morris.
He still sees us.
>> That's all the time, I'm afraid. So, I'd
like to thank Dan very much once again.
>> GERMAIN: Thank you.
END